I'm going to show you guys how to whip
up some beans in like under 20 minutes
which is like what it's unheard of right
dude who has 3 hours to cook beans so
what you want to do is you want to
measure out your beans and you want to
roast them no need to put oil or
anything nor water or anything we're
just going to roast them a little bit
we're going to have them nice and toasty
so once they're roasted you're going to
want to put them in the blender any type
of blender I pop them into my little
blendjet
here SL bad boy got some power put a
little bit of oil on your pan one chili
jalapeno a little bit of onion and
garlic
so then once your beans are nicely
grounded down into some powder I'm going
to pour them
in add some
water salt to taste if you listen
closely yep those are beans add enough
water and let them simmer for about 10
minutes put a lid on it so it's been
about 20 25
minutes and look at what we have woo